we can
[Music]
hey
folks hope everybody is doing well
my day is
not been what I planned it's been bad
necessarily just
um
I had certain things I thought it was
going to get done today and uh that uh
that's not what happened anyways
hope everybody's doing well
and
um
did my hair just get shorter I mean I
two weeks ago was the stream revealing
the haircut it's
this was the cut I didn't get it cut
again if that's what you're asking
ah
but I hope people had a lovely weekend I
did have a very nice weekend
yeah that was that was quite nice
um
how's life
exhausting at the moment
um
that that is one of those questions that
the answer is gonna vary greatly
um
depending on when you ask me
a couple of things
uh first is we have a hard stop time at
eight to the today because I have
another stream to get to that is not
technically immediately after this but
is pretty soon after this
um so it um I have to be on it uh an
hour after the stream ends but like
logging in and getting brought in on it
and making sure that all that
um happens the way it's supposed to I I
need I need a buffer uh for that uh that
stream for the record I'll mention it
again when I have to end it
um is the uh transcend VR charity stream
uh which is over on azeals uh YouTube
channel AZ uh eal a bunch of awesome
people have already been on it a bunch
of awesome people are going to be on it
it was originally going to be one day it
has turned into a week so but yeah I'll
be on that for a chunk of time after
this wraps up which does mean we have a
hard stop at at eight eastern daylight
time so
56 minutes
from when I said that
um
hard stock goes right how much emphasis
are you gonna put on the word hard
in that case oh it's a hard stop
oh no we're not gonna stop gender we're
gonna stop
we're gonna stop hard
[Laughter]
it's like channeling the worst read of
Christian Gray
I don't make love
I
hard
almost said it not gonna
last the whole stream a little sleepy
tonight that is fair pirates that is
that is more than fair what am I eating
I'm eating raspberries
and posted two alternate questions one
in the Discord I'll go and delete one of
them if you're on if you've watched any
of the ghosts of Molly McGee season two
have I I have not
um I have not I did not realize season
two was out yet I'll have to let the
kiddo know
Michael Palin's wife passed away oh
that's a bummer
uh if you never went into YouTube what
would your career in uh what would be
your career in an alternative timeline
I don't know
I'd probably be stuck in another office
job miserable
the thing is like
here's again where I'm
bad
at uh at engaging with those kinds of
questions is I can't settle into as much
of an alternate reality world as I I
would need to to give an interesting
answer
because an interesting answer would be
based off of well then I'd be pursuing
all these other interests I have except
I also pursue most of these other
interests that I have now I just don't
dedicate the most time to them
but things like novel writing Twitch
streaming the spicy site I don't think
any of them even if I dedicated myself
full-time to any one of them would
actually pay my bills so because I know
that the back of my head my answer
defaults to I'd still be stuck in an
office
like I love what I do as a YouTuber but
understand part of how I ended up here
doing this was of the many things I
enjoy doing that are creative this was
the one I could actually make a living
at
that doesn't mean I haven't tried at at
the past or even currently as a side
project doing a whole bunch of others
but none of them even like projecting
out to what would it look like if I did
that full-time I don't think I would
have been successful enough at any of
those and so I'd still be stuck in an
office
got to see Return of the Jedi in
theaters for the re-release my theater
cheered when when Vader threw Palpatine
into the Death Star pit yes sadly
somehow Palpatine came back
God that freaking line
uh
did you know the ghost of Molly McGee
music was written by Rob Cantor of tally
Hall and actual cannibal Shia lab of
Fame I did not know that
uh I'm gonna be a bride maze bridesmaid
for my cousin's wedding this Saturday
well I hope that that is an enjoyable
experience for you
ah
oh um reminder that while I will try and
keep up with the chat the only thing
that will guarantee I get to your
question is to do it as a super chat
that's just so that I'm not
um you know
trying to drive myself crazy trying to
keep up with the thing which
I tend to do sometimes anyways but
have I seen her listen to the musical
and Juliet No I know it exists
that's about all I've got
yeah no I I I've never seen nor heard it
I haven't listened to a
a musical that's new to me and
a couple of years
I mean I suppose
like I suppose you can count Shrek
because I went and saw that performed
live but like it's not like I downloaded
the script afterwards
so
I don't know that's that's not quite
what I think
nice uh HP haga very nice
uh delete that question with the ghost
brother in it thank you 255 A.D that is
very courteous of you I appreciate it
greatly
have you seen have you seen in War of
the Worlds Musical and I was that
different from the musical concept album
because I've heard that
is there like a proper stage musical
version because
um
hmm
favorite prehistoric creatures not
dinosaurs or of the Mesozoic Era oh
I don't know
I legit don't know
dinosaurs were the kind of the most
interesting thing going on because
mammals are mostly just rodents
I don't know
saber-toothed tiger is kind of
interesting
handy in my dissertation this week it's
about the issues of England's
prostitution laws which criminalize sex
why criminalizing sex work is a bad idea
it is it's a terrible idea Ben 100
percent
criminalizing sex work is
counterproductive stupid and harmful
on just about every level
and it's especially I'm gonna go off on
a little bit now if uh
it's all the same to you but
it's especially galling
when people who pass
anti-sex work laws of any kind
try to claim that they're doing it to
protect women
because they always frame it that way
even though people of all genders get
engaged in sex work but they claim it is
to protect women from being victims
nearly every
single thing
that is dangerous about sex work in
general and prostitution in specific is
only dangerous because it's illegal
it is dangerous because they can't go to
the police would there still be some
hazard in the line of work yes however
the reason the the rights of abuse of
um in-person full-service sex workers is
so high is because they can't go to the
police without immediately having to
confess confess to the crime of
prostitution
so it is
safe
for people to mistreat them because they
won't get reported
people bring up pimps the reason that
street workers
historically needed pimps was because
they needed someone who at least
theoretically would protect them from
all the people who would abuse them and
neither of those things would would be
part of the equation if they could just
go to the authorities and say hey
this client abused me
but they can't
criminalizing sex work does nothing
but
just make life more difficult
for all sex workers of every kind
so
yeah I could I could I could really I
could keep going off I'll bring it back
I'll bring it back bring it back
have you seen good luck Leo Grande the
film has an amazing positive look into
into sex work I have not I haven't heard
of that one
so I know I'm not familiar
I know you've covered it twice but can
you do reality split into one doctor
saves Gallifrey 12th doctor explodes the
TARDIS
there for the doctor is the time of
child is timeless child and isn't two
timelines created from one die in the
Titleist explodes look
look you can do that if you want I just
ignore it
just ignore the Timeless child like
here's the thing
I'm not trying to invalidate anybody who
really cannot let go
of of the nature of the Timeless child
Revelation like I've got enough Hang-Ups
in my brain where there's stuff that
like I just can't get over can't roll
with or can't adjust my brain to work
with so when I say just ignore it if you
can't I'm not trying to shame you for
that but for me and speaking strictly
from my perspective because ultimately
it's the only perspective I've got
I don't see how anything that you would
have to do to try and actively retcon
undo or correct it
is worth it when you could just ignore
it and move on like we did with the half
human [__] from The Eighth Doctor's
movie
just summed up my dissertation better
than me well said Vera oh great do I get
a degree
uh
criminalizing sex work is only to make
people doing it
feels Superior I'm gonna disagree with
that Joel criminalizing sex work is done
to control women
now again to be clear all genders
participate in sex work of all kinds
however it is perceived as being
something that women do
and it is perceived as women being
allowed to
basically have enough authority over
their own bodies that they can
care for themselves and get their own
income without having to engage in the
systems that are built
to ignore them by and large because no
matter what you think of
the overall society that we live in the
structures of it the foundation was
built on a foundation of white supremacy
and misogyny now that does not mean that
everyone who lives in our society even
at the time it was founded was a white
supremacist or a misogynist but these
are two things baked into the system
and women having the power to basically
just
offer themselves at a price of their
choosing under circumstances that they
approve of
that is power that people are not that
people with power are not comfortable
with women having
and that is the overriding motivation
more often than not
as to why there is the push to
criminalize sex work
um and you know prostitution in
particular but sex work in general and
like I remember being so confused I
forget how old I was I remember being so
confused
when it was worded to me that
prostitutes sell their body for money
that made absolutely no sense to me just
that statement or why that was different
from anyone else
because how is it
that offering your body
for the purpose of someone else's
interactions with it that will grant
them pleasure fundamentally different
from offering your body
to lift heavy objects to cut down trees
to do anything else if you can offer
your body for labor
what makes that labor different what
makes that labor wrong
I have a feeling this is going to be the
thing I keep coming back to this whole
stream I'm just going to own it at this
point
during my graduation I'll yell I'm a
fraud on stage and tell everyone to go
subscribe to your Channel
I won't stop you
Stars Emma Thompson's real sex positive
I ended up feeling so much better by the
end of the movie I watched on Amazon
Prime I don't know if it's on anything
else I I will try to look into it I
can't promise there's so much stuff I'm
behind on I would argue controlling
woman and wanting to feel Superior very
much go together fair but I think the
sense of superiority by most of the
people who passed these laws uh CIS
straight
white men
um are the sense of superiority again is
baked in but yeah no that that's not
wrong
the script for mcu's Ned CEO of sex
would have been about Ned making sex
work legal Nationwide I hope it leaves
development and Allen makes it into
phase five that would be an interesting
pitch
foreign
and selling their body's narrative is so
toxic it encourages abusive behavior and
Johnson well yeah
because wording like that presumes that
once money has changed hands
their body is yours to do with as you
will you now own it for the period of
time you have paid for
which is the um
the inherent implication of that kind of
language
do you watch Verity Richie nope I don't
have a clue who that is
Avatar fan 10 000. I had to see how many
zeros were there thank you very much for
the Super Chat you get a heart from me I
just want to say I love your content and
I'm happy to see you live oh thank you
I'm happy to have you here
have you ever had strawberry brownies
with white chocolate chips
I've been on strawberry brownies at all
I'm like I can be very simple when it
comes to stuff like that it gets over
complicated it's like oh here's this
thing that's normally this flavor but
we've injected it with this and added
this I'm like that's whoa slow down
did you watch the Met Gala I didn't even
know it was a thing until I saw a clip
of the Cockroach that the photographer
took pictures of as if it was strutting
the runway
I
yeah see I would ask do I look like I
care about fashion except that like I've
obviously put a little work into my
appearance so like I care how I look but
I I super don't care about fashion in
the broad Strokes in the abstract as a
thing that people engage with like I so
don't care
uh just arrived are we talking about
mtg's recent Crusade against PornHub oh
is that a thing now
we weren't though it fits into the
general nonsense we've been talking
about
there was someone dressed up as a cat
like
like cheap Halloween costume or like
proper furry because if they were if if
they actually had like proper fursuited
folks go down the um
go down the runway at the Met Gallop
then I might pay attention
PornHub cut off Utah I missed that one
[Laughter]
oh
no falling for you
MTG is crazy I don't
I mean I'm I'm always hesitant to call
anybody crazy
her public Persona is unhinged
absolutely
I openly question
how many of these people
who are the loudest
are actually to that extreme and I don't
mean this and I'll give them a benefit
that way I mean in a if you do [__] that
gets you attention
why would you stop doing it
if she gets more attention saying
absolutely insane [__] why would she
stop
like she was a she was a q Anon person
before she was
in Congress so like literally acting
like
she was completely detached from reality
got her into office why would she stop
to the point that from a certain logic
it even makes sense to Crank It Up more
attention more spotlight
xHamster always also cut off Utah cool
[__] Utah
[Laughter]
was my favorite and least favorite
Doctor Who episode currently favorite is
still the Dr fosley's favorite is idiots
lantern that one will probably never
change I still think Magic the Gathering
when I see MTG yeah I do too it takes me
a second I need the context cues
am I okay with you calling Yee crazy
I think he's high getting off his meds
uh
here's what I will say
if you want to have
an actual conversation about the
acknowledged fact acknowledged by him
that he has bipolar disorder
and you want to have a conversation
about his actions through the lens of
that I don't necessarily have a problem
with that but being that I don't have uh
a lot of
deep understanding
um
and as far as bipolar
uhness goes
and I say that as someone who's like
I'm not unfamiliar I'm familiar with how
it can manifest but it also manifest
some very personalized ways
and
there's a conversation to be had there
I don't think
this is the appropriate place to do it
but
uh
so she's probably 40 60 on the grifter
actually unhinged scale
[Music]
what are my thoughts on video game
movies and TV shows then versus now
largely unchanged
what I will grant
is I am I am at this point certainly
more open to
um
I'm I'm more open to TV show adaptations
of video games than I am felt
I I have a very difficult time picturing
any video game that would make a
legitimately good film that having been
said we have now had two
legitimately good TV series based off
video games one was Castlevania the
other was the last of us what I will say
though is
that those should not be taken as a
measure for oh great the tv shows will
be awesome not necessarily with the last
of us it's worth noting you talk to
people about those games long enough and
most of them will acknowledge the story
was probably always going to work better
outside of a video game context than in
it so that was a story that honestly
probably should have been a show from
the first uh
point at what you started and with
Castlevania that has
shockingly deep and shockingly coherent
lore to draw to draw from it actually
doesn't
try to retell the story of a specific
video game it pulls a bit from
Castlevania 3 and a little bit from
Symphony of the Night but a lot of it's
just just pulling the lore together and
if you can get a particularly talented
writer and I again I know Warren Ellis
is a problematic person now but he's a
very talented writer to pull all that
together and give him the freedom to do
it
yeah no that worked I'm I am unconvinced
of video game movies
ever really working
at all
like
I'm not gonna say they're all going to
be terrible we'll probably top out at
okay that was fine
and that's probably as good as it'll
ever get
I haven't seen much of your opinion on
video games what am I into well if you
head on over to the break room of Geeks
I actually do review video games every
now and then I tend to play retro uh
retro style if not actual retro games
largely because fully rendered 3D has a
tendency to make me motion sick and so
most of the uh big budget mainstream
games that come out now are just
completely off the table they will make
me want to throw up and so I play a lot
of a lot of Metroid videos a lot of
roguelikes you know various things of
that nature Point click Adventures still
somewhat
ah that sort of thing
I don't think people like MTG or Trump
are introspective enough to actually
have real beliefs make sense
like I don't ever think I say this but
this is what I actually believe
um
I would agree
Trump
because if you look on him on a long
enough time scale
um oh Arcane thank you John vinyls yes
that is the other one that is very good
um
and because like again not really based
off the game itself diving into the lore
and reshaping a lot of it so yes we are
we are up to three very good series but
anyway I would say that that statement
255 A.D is much more true of trump than
of MTG
because you know Trump has literally
flip-flopped 180 degrees for no apparent
reason other than he seems to think it's
what would get him the best reaction to
whoever he's talking to or it's what he
can somehow cash in on for clout or
money or whatever he probably
legitimately has no belief Beyond will
this
give will this benefit me
MTG has had a much narrower frame of the
things that she says and pushes for that
is more
it is philosophically consistent enough
that there's probably some underlying
beliefs there
Trump's all over the goddamn place he'll
just say whatever
like he legit doesn't care
um
so I'd say if it's true of anybody it's
probably true of him
are you perchance an FTL fan I do like
FTL pickles I haven't played it in a bit
but I do like that one
War analysis like a one Michelin star
Chef who will sous vide the greens to
Perfection but treats his staff
dreadfully that's an interesting
comparison
not awful
have I ever been to a bottle redemption
center
I mean probably as a kid we probably
took a field trip to one
not sure if there was a lead-in to that
question
detective Pikachu is an outlier on that
point I think detective Pikachu is
probably about the best one that we've
had so far and even that one like it's
cute it's sweet
I forget it exists
to be honest
uh
why would Trump care no matter what he
says his followers stick by him
Trump may not not have beliefs his
followers do
he has tapped into people with very
strong beliefs
and every now and then he steps on the
wrong side of that that happened
when
he tried to encourage a group
that supported him to get the vaccine
because he knew it worked and he thought
he could benefit from it because the
vaccine was developed under his watch
he thought he could cash in on that and
when he tried to encourage a crowd of
his supporters to get the vaccine he was
booed
they won't follow him no matter what
but they don't care if he's inconsistent
nor do they care or if he's horrible
they believe that he will accomplish the
things they want to happen
in this country but if and when he
directly stands in the way of that or
appears to take a position contradictory
to it they don't put up with it
the thing is ultimately
Trump has no plan he he creates policy
by Vibe basically says he basically goes
by what what gets a pop at the rallies
cool I'll do that
it's it's it's almost it's almost
holistic governance
the culture story where they first visit
Earth is sent in 1977 but Banks wrote it
in 1990s that an odd Choice like that it
uh be like us setting a Sci-Fi book in
2010 for no reason
I'd have to read it to figure out
whether or not the 1970s setting
benefits the story in any specific way
um
because depending on the way the culture
is taken in uh maybe a mid late 70s
cultural perspective
directly influences the way the story
pans out and it wouldn't pan out the
same way said in another decade that's
me speculating
Supreme
Omega thank you very much I'm Buffy
thoughts on the sixth season aka the
really dark season with Willow's
addiction Bobby's depression and the
musical episode pros and cons well keep
in mind I have not re-watched any of
Buffy and hey
long time
I tended to go back and forth as to
whether I thought the second season
or the sixth season was the best season
of the show
now again I don't know if I still stand
by that sentiment but I can tell you it
used to be my sentiment that it was in
in contention for the best season with
season two
um I thought it was really good
I don't know how I'd feel about it now
if I were to re-watch it but there's a
lot of good stuff in it
the musical episode is legitimately
great
they did a surprisingly good job of
um actually having Dawn work for me a
bit better after her actual Arc in the
previous season
um
I thought the Willow's addiction thing
was a little clumsy but I did find the
dark Willow elements to be very
um engaging certainly grabbed my
attention
um and
season six also has one of my all-time
favorites
character returning to a show after a uh
period away moments in all of Television
spoilers for Buffy season six
so Willow has gone full back at this
point she's already flayed Warren and
she is just embracing being evil
and she says to Buffy
I might not have the exact words out but
it's basically there isn't a force on
Earth that could stop me
and suddenly she is flung back into a
set of bookcases and there stands Giles
who has been gone since Midway through
the season and he just says I'd like to
test that theory
I love it so much
am I going to react to the Doom part 2
trailer ah crap is it out
damn it
ah
[__] trailers man oh hey Meg I'm glad
you made it good to see you
hideous Lantern was covered in and on
the cover of the latest cartoon magazine
probably only because of the new
coronation they didn't mention the
ending at all of course it didn't
I mean like if you're going to say
anything positive about the episode you
kind of can't talk about that ending
because it removes anything else
positive about the the episode that
ending is harmful
it is legitimately a dangerous message
so
Jared Leto was dressed up in the
Michaela and a cat fursuit costume and
all my furry friends are like he isn't
part of us
I would swiftly disown Jared Leto too
is it weird that I really enjoyed doing
part one but a little to no excitement
for part two I a ton of excitement for
part two but it's partly because I was
not
nearly as bowled over by part one as
seemingly every other
pundit critic Creator whatever on this
platform in the freaking planet seemed
to be
everybody lost their minds so many
people who I watch are like had it in
their top 10 at the end of the year
um some people had it as their number
one I'm like really
like it was good don't get me wrong but
I was like really
really
ah
am I the only one who thinks Buffy is
insanely overrated and mid at best I
think one's opinion of Buffy has a lot
to do with when you came to it it was
it was quite a thing for its time
but yeah
apologies in advance if I take anybody
off with this comparison but I'll do it
anyway I feel about it a little bit
um like how I feel about Avatar The Last
Airbender
which was that it was seminal when it
came out massively influential
but so many things have done what it did
and some things have done it better and
things as a whole have moved forward
that if you weren't there to see it
at or close to the time when it aired to
appreciate how fresh it was in the
moment then going back to it some years
after the fact yeah it comes off as okay
and I make the comparison because I do
have a love of Buffy because I
experienced it pretty soon after it
wrapped up and I don't have that love
for Avatar because I experienced it
years and years and years later but I
suspect if I'd watched avatar The Last
Airbender at the time I probably would
have liked it very much
you'd have to read it you will that's
the state of the art oh okay well you'll
get my full thoughts on that eventually
um
ever heard of the various mythological
stories about the world being formed
from the corpse of a giant
yeah here and there I don't know them uh
particularly well though
speaking of trump uh do we have to I
know I went off on him for a minute but
okay Deep South supporters of him were
asked if he told you to get the vaccine
would you and the guy's response was why
would I he's a liberal New Yorker
[Laughter]
sums it up like
for him
to the extent that he will get them what
they want or they think he will
the reporter asked why did you vote from
the guy said he was the only good choice
of the two options um
I had such a crush on such a Jaws it's
such a crush on Giles for some reason
the reason was it was Anthony Stewart
had and it is valid I know a credit who
prefers the David Lynch Dune movie to
the new one that's
that's a take
I could see an argument where
someone could potentially find the David
Lynch movie more interesting
it's not better
I got all
um
can I impersonate Beavis and Butthead I
can
don't really feel like it though
I'm finally gonna see the Super Mario
Brothers movie tomorrow night stoked
awesome Meg you'll have to let me know
what you think of it
and let me know how Bowser's song is
what you think of that
is the guy at the beginning of a new
hope the only person Vader kills with
his bare hands no Force Power no
lightsaber
um
he might be I mean arguably there's a
little Force Power for him to get the
lift the one hand lift
on the neck
but uh yeah it could be
the Dune movie did something I love the
technology is exactly like it is in the
book written in 1965 they didn't update
it at all yeah that I yeah I respect
that as well
I shipped Aaron Willow so hard still
didn't figure out I was queer for a long
time oh that's a mood
who was the Avatar character you didn't
like
there's a few characters I don't super
care for but
the character who people in the comments
told me that I would like who I didn't
was tough
Toff really didn't work for me
she rubbed me the wrong way
support him because he'll get us what we
want is the extent of my support for
Biden am I in August to a trump
supporter
no because you're more honest about it
I think a lot of people well this is
true of the right in general
um a lot of people get very very
invested in
The Narrative of what the right is
supposed to be it's why you don't get a
lot of self-criticism on the right
um other than like weird [__]
infighting
and
they tend to get in lock step
whether that's out of a conscious choice
of if we or at least they try to like
they're dealing with infighting right
now and the set and the uh in the house
and whatnot but
like the supporters by and large
tend to want enough of the same thing
the thing is with people like Biden
for me it's not even a case of I voted
for Biden because he'll get us what we
want I voted for Biden because it was
damage mitigation he will do less to
destroy everything than well Trump in
particular or honestly probably anybody
on the right
so for me it wasn't even really support
of Biden it was what's the least harmful
option
so I do think there is a difference
I always feel like my to-do list is
rarely finished stress is stupidly
constant oh Meg
boy do I fail you on that
I met Anthony Stewart head and asked him
how was it to work with Elizabeth sladen
and he said she was chuffed that's cute
uh
yeah then he Stewart had singing on The
Rocky Horror karaoke show was lit I've
I've only seen like a small clip of
clip of
uh
uh I get it make wrangling v as a whole
thing ah
okay what
yeah no it's it's true I
I don't thank you enough for uh
for trying to Wrangle my
nonsense brain
I don't know why you put up with me but
thank you for doing so
I wish more sci-fi adaptations of old
books did that like I want to see what a
visualization of what the author had in
their head at the time not what seems
plausible now that is one of the things
that like
to a certain extent I appreciate that
some of the Star Trek stuff is done so
like things like Star Trek strange
strange new worlds has updated and
streamlined the look of things a little
bit so it's not quite as blocky it's not
so aesthetically 60s but like
we live in an age where we have
smartphones that do way more than a
freaking communicator and and the
original Star Trek did but they've still
got them with those because that's what
they had in the show so we keep them so
yeah I get what you're saying
why didn't I like Toff I didn't like
Toff because
she was the kind of person whose
response to literally everything was
negativity and it's not that I don't
mind cynical characters I can be a very
cynical person
and I can appreciate cynical characters
but people who seem to take their
existence is just
oh thing good no thing bad actually
was just that was just the feel I got
offer and maybe she's better in the last
season
I didn't finish it still don't plan to
Laura's how not only have I seen repo
the Genetic Opera I did a whole video on
that you can look it up
first part of the eight part big finish
60th anniversary story drops today great
I can't afford it so
um
I have the entire Rocky Horror karaoke
thing recording recorded ooh
I might uh
we might we might need to set that up as
a thing
uh
Super Fan Avatar superfan as I like the
long fan of avatar The Last Airbender
and
I suspected you might have been I think
Toff is good but if you don't like
characters who are apathetic you might
not like her yeah I'm I I actually you
know what that's a really good
distinction I can deal with cynical
characters apathetic really can rub me
the wrong way it's rare that I engage
well with an apathetic character
because if you come across like you just
aren't invested in much of anything
like why would I be invested in you
it's been long enough that I even tried
watching the back end of um
of Avatar that like I can't even say
that with a ton of certainty because my
memories are fading but anyway I need to
jump on the Discord I gotta tackle those
questions uh and apologies to anyone who
dropped questions on the Discord I did
say and it looks like not everybody
noticed that I'm only doing two
questions per person this time because
um I do have the hard stop at eight
but here we go my friends and I were
talking a couple weeks ago about how DC
could overtake Marvel this year How
likely do you think that is especially
now with the writer strike going on well
the writers strike shouldn't impact very
much this year the ripple effect of the
writers strike is well I say it
shouldn't affect much this year it
shouldn't affect much of the kind of
stuff Marvel and DC do this year
um the ripple effect of a rider strike
generally tends to hit anything that has
a really fast turnaround time so you
know things like late night shows
Saturday Night Live South Park which is
turned around in like a week stuff like
that gets hit immediately everything
else you're actually not going to see
the effects until a bit later when
um
things being made off of uh of
incomplete or cobbled together or
quickly the strikes ended we need to get
back on top of this and we need to keep
a schedule those things start happening
um or you know movies that were rushed
into production on unfinished unfinished
scripts before the strike started those
movies and those projects aren't going
to come out until next year ah all right
damn it I was hoping this wouldn't
happen but Ah that's bugging me
hope that doesn't Skee of anybody but
stupid lash was poking me a little bit I
gotta get rid of that anyways
so I don't think the writer strike is
really going to truly have its effects
felt especially stuff like DC and Marvel
this year could DC overtake Marvel this
year I mean
I think a lot of it's going to come down
to whether or not people actually turn
out for the Flash
and I don't know if they will I'm not
planning to see it but
plenty of people will
do you think the culture is a
particularly humorous series like would
you mention it if you were recommending
it to someone loads of videos and even
academic essays analyzing the series
philosophy and no one ever talks about
its humor
the thing is there is a lot of good
humor in the culture stories
um
you know but a lot of it's character
based and it's not like the core of a
lot of what's going on
it's individual scenes or it's one
character
um again demycin comes to mind who I
really loved and I found quite funny
quite often but
I don't feel like humor is a it is a
recurrent aspect as opposed to a Core
theme so if you're going to do a deep
dive on it humor would be a slightly odd
thing to choose to focus on or or to
highlight excessively it's there
certainly but it's it's not
it's not the heart of what the series is
at least from what I've taken in of it
if you're writing a period piece would
you give your protagonist period
appropriate morality I.E uh and the and
thus uh risk making them less
sympathetic or simply give them modern
see me morality even though it'll seem
anachronistic a few years ago I read a
book series that was about an
aristocratic Roman teenager who's an
outcast because of a facial deformity
runs away from a home to become a
gladiator and ends up in spartacus's
Army the thing is part of his backstory
is he lost his virginity by ordering his
family slaves to sleep with him and
throughout the series he never questions
if that is wrong like it's not even
brought up more than once could you have
sympathy for a protagonist who thinks
like this I think
making the choice to fully commit to the
morals of the time and the society in a
historical setting even for a
protagonist you are meant to like is a
risky move to make I personally would
not make it now that doesn't necessarily
mean you need to do a 180 and write them
as if oh they totally understand that
slavery is wrong or like my preference
in a situation like that would be to
write that
you know his family just isn't well off
to own that many slaves and like avoid
it
um would be probably my personal option
on that because it is it is difficult
um even though it is more accurate to do
that and again it's a choice I can
understand
it's not one I'd make though
if it was a character I was genuinely
trying to get people to like loved your
cameo and DW 2012 were you following a
script or were you allowed to add lib
okay so if folks uh have not already
seen it dw2012 has for years now been
doing a series of Doctor Who uh fan uh
films and in their most recent one
called I believe the most hated man on
Earth uh I and a number of other
YouTubers make Cameo appearances
basically
sort of as ourselves but not quite
um and it was a little bit of both on
that Jen I was given a script but um I
was told like if you want to rework this
a little so that it fits your voice
better or add a little bit to it go
ahead and so I was working off a script
but I was not
following the exact letter of that
script
will there be audio versions of your
book coming out in the future yes yes I
need to edit I need to finish edit the
freaking thing it takes forever
who's charity live stream for the
podcast currently how far are you ahead
are you with recording uh the charity
live stream that I will be I will be
going on uh at nine eastern daylight
time
um is transcend VR on azio's channel
that's
a-z-e-a-l it is um it is for Trans
causes and um trans activism Etc and
with the podcast with jump gate we are
two weeks ahead at present we've been
further ahead than that before and we
may try and get further ahead than that
again in the future but that's where we
are right now
oh this one had three questions I'm only
gonna tackle the first two I recently uh
fell ahead first in the world of Neil
Gaiman Sandman I have ever and have read
the entire series as well as watch the
first season on Netflix taking another
calm taking other comic book adaptations
into account do you think Netflix series
should will differ more from the path of
the original comic series
um
I think
I mean I did a whole video talking about
how good I think
um Netflix's Sandman is as an adaptation
largely because of the differences it
makes if you want a super loyal
adaptation there's the uh audible
audiobooks those are super loyal
um this was a chance to do something a
little bit different and I'm glad they
and I'm glad they took it and I would be
curious to what other changes get made
down the line
after seeing your video on the Harry
Potter HBO series and how Warner seems
desperate to make money with the IP do
you think it's mainly backlash against
Rowling for her beliefs or is it just a
symptomatic of changing pop culture
altogether I think it's both
I think
um I think in large part
Harry Potter has not been latched on to
to the younger generation Beyond
whatever parents read it directly to
their kids and that's a dwindling thing
um
and just will be you you can't super
grow uh Ultra loyal fan bases that way
um so I think I think it's a combination
I think pop culture as a whole is moving
on
um and you know young people are finding
other stuff they're finding stuff that
is new and more of the now that they're
gravitating towards more than Harry
Potter in the first place
do you think the Space Opera along with
its subsidiary the space Western is one
of the more imaginative genres given the
fact one can create vast expansive
galaxies races and colleges of species
not worried too much about clashing with
other established entities
um I wouldn't say it's necessarily more
imaginative there's a lot more freedom
I'll give you that that net doesn't
necessarily make it more imaginative
because some people have their
imaginations Thrive under restrictions
and some people when you give them all
the options in the world just come up
with something really Bland so there's a
lot more freedom
imagination is not inherent to the genre
though
what are your thoughts on the idea that
the Hulk may be non-binary
that's new
hadn't heard that one there is there is
some evidence of this in Canon such as
Hulk referring to himself is not a man
but simply his Hulk I'm en being myself
so it could be some Wishful projecting
on my part do you think it's an
interesting idea it's an interesting
idea I think
I don't think there's too much I can
think of that would at least in the MCU
version of the Hulk that would openly
contradict it
I because Hulk does seem to think of
himself as separate certainly separate
from Banner
um but you know separate from people in
general
but
I I would hesitant see when Hulk says
when Hulk says something to the extent
of not being a man
my own personal suspicion is that that
has more to do with not feeling like
human so like man as in human being and
less to do with man as in male gender
but there's certainly no reason you
couldn't interpret it that way
how important do you think story is in
video games depends on the video game
some genres it's incredibly important
point-and-click Adventure
um things like that which are basically
narrative with minimal gameplay you
better nail your story otherwise
if you've nailed a really entertaining
and enjoyable core gameplay Loop that is
fun to do regardless of the context
wrapping a nice context around it will
make it better but
um it's difficult to argue whether or
not it's important I don't think it's
always true but I do think what John
Carmack said about uh story and video
games which is if you don't know this
quote he said that video that story in
video games is a bit like story in porn
it's kind of nice to have but it's not
the thing anybody's there for I don't
think that is always true and actually I
think it's kind of increasingly uh it's
true increasingly less often
but it is definitely still sometimes
true
given that in Star Wars droids can be
owned and made to follow orders do you
think that the increasing Trend to show
them as having complex emotion and a
level of self-awareness might become
problematic oh it's already problematic
you think about the droids for more than
two seconds it's actually a big problem
I was recently watching an episode of
the Mandalorian where Amanda pushes a
Droid that clearly didn't want to leave
its owner and then later in that episode
forced it to uh to explore dangerous
environment against his wishes so that
he didn't need to risk his own life and
the whole thing made me draw
uncomfortable apparels to slavery and
abuse or controlling relationships yeah
uh Star Wars has yet to properly grapple
with the fact that droids are slaves
because they are clearly sentient and
have always been depicted as having
agency and their own thoughts and their
own emotions but are just disposable
labor
Star Wars has yet to Grapple with that
and it's not necessarily obligated to
but the longer it goes on and it doesn't
and especially when moments like that
show up in the newer stuff the more it's
like
anyways popping back
don't have too much time left but oh we
got some more Super chats in here we go
Supremo Mega on Harry Potter back in the
90s and 2000s did people not realize the
more problematic elements like the house
elves the goblins and green guts Etc
some people didn't
I didn't I definitely didn't notice the
goblins on my own reading the house
elves I didn't fully think about it I
did think it was weird that it was
brought up and not properly dealt with
um but I didn't fully think about it I
think the thing is a lot of it has to do
with being in a position of privilege
fundamentally privilege is the privilege
to not have to think about certain
things
and a lot of the reader base of Harry
Potter are privileged enough to not have
to think about
racial allegories or anti-semitists or
or anti-semitic
um
visual coding and tropes and so yeah a
lot of people did flat out miss it and a
lot of us had to be told I did now it's
just a question of when you are told
whether you decide to be a dick and go
like no uh or if you go oh
hmm
well that's a thing isn't it and then
move on however you need to
uh South Park is non-union screw them
are they I did not realize that
that well it's animated it would be
oh
um oh and thank you for the Super Chat
255 A.D and Supremo Mega back once more
I'm Robin while I feel Jason Todd should
have stayed dead yes
victim blaming does bother me in the
comics because nobody blames his mom who
betrayed him
the thing is
like I thought I've never really blamed
Jason for his own death
I guess some people do
but
um in any case like
I
I only kind of briefly read I kind of
skimmed through death in the family
years ago so like I don't have a super
strong opinion about his mother as she
was portrayed in there but yeah there's
certainly if you're gonna lay blame
her and the Joker would uh have the Lion
Share and possibly Batman for putting
him in that situation at all since he
was a child but that's also why he's
most interesting dead because he is the
worst possible consequences of what
Robin is and Batman should have had to
live with that said bring him back from
the freaking dead anyways stress is
creepy in nice to be here with you all
take it easy thank you for stopping in
Meg I need to wrap it up anyway because
I need to prep for the next Stream So
that uh brings up what is coming up
in about an hour I will be on azio's uh
stream and I'll be there for a chunk of
time and we'll talk about
whatever
um
do the Abominations in the house suffer
from the same problem as house elves or
droids they they do not exhibit anywhere
near the same level of sentience
now that doesn't mean that they exhibit
no sentience but they're not even close
to the same uh amount so no John that
wouldn't be the same
um
uh apparently there is a uh
yes uh Dharma I'll I'll send the link to
the Discord
um apparently there is a uh a trailer
for the next Dune so I'll have a
reaction to that out I don't know
tomorrow most likely and then tomorrow
also
um I'll be on Twitch in the morning 10
30 a.m eastern daylight time I believe
if I remember correctly Carolyn we're
starting persona 5.
which I've not played any of the Persona
games so we'll see how that goes
um
and yeah Saturday will be
on uh will be my thoughts on the
potential for R-rated Marvel films
and yeah that's what's coming up the
rest of this week
thanks everybody for joining me sorry I
couldn't like go a little bit over time
like I usually do but yeah I got other
stuff I need I need to jump on and deal
with
uh so I hope everybody has a uh a great
rest of the day a great rest of the week
I'm sure I will see some of you well
some of you will see me I don't know how
much interaction there is with the chat
but uh some of you will see me on azio's
live stream in a little bit
um and some of you will see me in the
morning on Twitch but in any case
remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you're loved
damn it I felt that
I had a seed I had a seed from a
raspberry at the back of my throat I'm
like
I can hold it off and get through my
outro and I didn't
ah
you're beautiful you're valid you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
recovery